what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the brand new major
developments in the blog clovers story
including the introduction of a new
extremely powerful character a character
that could potentially be a villain
although we don't know yet for sure this
character is also possibly connected to
a new demon who has been hinted at in
the story but not officially shown
finally this new extremely old P
character may have a direct connection
to noel silva through her mother ah CA
silva this last part is my own theory
that I talked about in a video from a
few weeks ago so this is not a spoiler
or anything like that it's just a theory
of mine that I'd love to hear your
thoughts on after you've seen the video
through to the end
if you enjoyed the black clover content
on this channel and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime abroad
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications the way that YouTube works
now if you don't hit that Bell and turn
on all notifications you will definitely
miss a lot of our videos feel free to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest black
clover news and updates and finally this
video will contain spoilers for two
black clover manga we're dealing with
the latest developments in the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in Chapter two to four of
the manga it is confirmed that the black
bulls will have to travel to the Hart
Kingdom in order to get to the bottom of
the demon curse that was detected within
its borders Yami says that there's no
way to get in because apparently the
Hart kingdom is surrounded by its own
unique brand of trap magic anyone who
trips a trap will be instantly marked as
a criminal and it will become an
international incident drawing way too
much negative attention and tanking the
mission before it even starts
Noel points out that her cousin mimosa
has been to the heart Kingdom once
before apparently some of the nobles
from the clover Kingdom have been
travelling abroad for their studies and
the Hart Kingdom is an option for those
students this immediately tells us that
the Hart and clover kingdoms have
relatively friendly relations since this
type of cooperation and exchange would
not
be possible between warring kingdoms
this also shows that the Hart Kingdom is
fairly open to foreigners and it is not
some completely closed off totalitarian
state at least as far as we know at this
point as the black bulls rushed to
finish eating and get out of the capital
before damnatio and the Royals start
getting on their case
FINRA travels to the headquarters of the
Golden Dawn to get in touch with mimosa
about her previous travels to the Hart
Kingdom while he's there
Finn Hall visits his younger brother
languorous who is still in bed and
recovering from the elf possession and
the subsequent battles that he was
involved in fin Rollins being a nice and
caring big brother to languorous but
languorous is still extremely
disappointed in himself and the damage
that he did to their family and to the
kingdom but Finn well reassures language
that it wasn't his fault because he was
possessed by an elf
in addition fennel declares that
starting right now he's going to work
like he's never worked before in order
to become the man worthy of leading
their family the House of Vaud and on
top of that Finn reveals to become the
kind of man that is worthy of Lady
finesse and he vows to return and sweep
her off her feet once he completes his
mission this is a pretty ballsy move on
the part of Finn role he says all this
right in front of an s basically
declaring that he will become the head
of the house wad and marry her
languorous gets out of bed and leads
Finn wrong out of the room and away from
finesse out in the hallway he introduces
mineral to some cute Golden Dawn girls
and Finn wrong immediately proceeds to
hit on them Langridge then calls him out
on it saying that Finn Rahl's womanizing
is like a curse how could finra I'll
claim that he is serious about making
finesse happy when he can't stop himself
from hitting on every attractive woman
that he sees languorous tells Finn all
that he has to break his bad habit of
womanizing his curse otherwise he will
never be good enough for finesse and
languorous will marry her instead fin
Rollins face is all like damn he's got
me I gotta step it up and I really
appreciate the fact that here at
languorous is shown actually trying to
help his older brother
I mean language is kind of a stuck-up
douche so he isn't helping Finn roll in
an obvious way but by pointing out Finn
roles main flaw and then threatening to
marry finesse instead of him language is
actually doing a good job of motivating
Finn all to become a better
dare I say it there may still be some
hope for languorous as a character we
then jump to a conversation between Noel
Aastha and mimosa in which mimosa agrees
to help Austin the black Bulls learn
more about the heart Kingdom mimosa says
that when she was 13 she spent some time
studying inside the heart Kingdom with
her brother best boy in the Slovak
Adonis of black clover Kirsch Vermillion
mimosa explains that when they were
inside the heart Kingdom they were only
allowed to be within specifically
designated areas so the heart Kingdom is
open to foreigners but not that open
they don't let foreigners just wander
around everywhere on their own the heart
Kingdom clearly has some secrets that
they want to keep hidden the heart
Kingdom is also full of nature water and
all sorts of greenery and it is packed
with mana because of the incredible
amounts of nature that is all around the
kingdom the heart Kingdom also
apparently has magic technology that is
different from the magic technology of
the clover kingdom so there is a lot
that a clover kingdom mage can learn
from studying the heart kingdom and you
know what this means for the next arc
there's gonna be a lot of world building
including cool new types of magic mimosa
finds the idea that curses and demon
magic could be located within the heart
kingdom both incredibly terrifying and
hard to believe but Noel is committed to
learning as much as possible about these
potential demonic curses because she
hopes to find information that can help
her find the demon Meggie Kula the demon
who is apparently directly connected to
her mother and to her mother's alleged
death mimosa says that although she was
never able to meet her the ruler of the
Hart kingdom is a queen / princess that
is said to be more powerful than all of
the clover kingdoms magic Knights put
together by the way the word is either
princess or queen depending on which
translation you use but I prefer Queen
because it sounds more badass so I'm
gonna go with that
I'm not saying busines princesses ruined
all princesses for all time but there
you go anyway if these rumors about the
Queen's powers are actually true and not
just a legend it would make the heart
Kingdom Queen one of the strongest
characters in the entire series if we
take into account magic knight captain's
like Yami Fugo Leon and Dorothy the idea
that a single character could be more
powerful than all of them put together
seems
this might even make the Queen's power
comparable to the kotodama devil that
would definitely make for an interesting
new villain but I find it hard to
believe that this Queen could be so
powerful unless she has been using some
form of demonic magic or unless she was
perhaps cursed or possessed by a demon
perhaps she is the source of the curse
that was detected within the heart
kingdom mimosa says that during this
time of year the Hart kingdom tends to
accept applications for travelers and
visitors looking to enter the kingdom so
she handles the applications and the
next thing we know we have no el mimosa
Austin FINRA entering the Hart Kingdom
by boat
well actually Sucre is there too in her
Nero bird form the four of them plus
Nero were able to gain legal permission
to enter the kingdom but mimosa says
that she wasn't able to get permission
for a larger number of people so it
looks like for now it will be just the
five of them on this journey although
let's be real Yami will definitely
illegally infiltrate the kingdom at some
point for him entering Legally would be
just way too boring finra all starts
silently freaking out about the fact
that he is on a boat with two beautiful
royal girls and another beautiful girl
who can transform into a bird but he has
to keep his cool and not hit on anyone
in order to prove his loyalty to finesse
after passing through a fog that allows
only those with official permission to
come through Austin the gang get their
first glimpse of the Hart kingdom it is
a place absolutely swimming in natural
beauty and it reminds me of a tropical
rainforest like you would find somewhere
in the Amazon jungle the settlements
including the cities seem to be
intertwined with natural beauty
coexisting in harmony with the luscious
nature as Austin the gang marvel at the
beauty of the Hart Kingdom we see that
they are being watched by the Hart
kingdoms mysterious Queen the Queen says
that she must have the clover kingdoms
daemon power referring presumably to the
demon inside of Asta's grimoire and the
final page suggests that a secret scheme
is stirring and it is all connected to
demon magic the introduction of the
Queen is very mysterious and very
suspicious to me only a small portion of
her face is shown around the mouth as if
her face is deliberately being hidden
from us we haven't seen the face of this
Queen before so what's the point of
hiding it could it be that her face
hidden because once we see it we are
going to realize that she has the face
of someone we've already met in the
story beyond this blatant and deliberate
concealing of her face we also see a
large female magical entity hovering
above the Queen as she sits on her
throne is this panel telling us that the
queen is being possessed by some more
powerful entity perhaps an elf or demon
the entity above the Queen appears to
have long ears like an elf but perhaps
they are actually horns like a demon
it's too hard to tell for sure just from
that one single panel but at any rate
the Queen says that she wants the clover
kingdoms demon power this suggests that
she is fully aware that there is more
than one demon / devil and it is
possible that she knows this because she
is already aware of the demon inside the
heart Kingdom a demon that she might be
directly connected to I will also
mention that the entity which hovers
above the Queen seems to be surrounded
by a magic that looks a lot like the
mercury magic used by Nosal silva and
this is the same type of magic that was
once used by Noelle's mother ah ca silva
the one who was allegedly killed as a
result of a demon's curse remember what
i said in my previous block clover video
which focused on the master reveal about
the existence of another demon called
Meggie Kula the same demon who was
allegedly responsible for the death of
Noelle's mother we've all been told that
Noelle's mother died as a result of a
curse placed on her by the demon Meggie
Kula but that description of her death
is pretty vague if you ask me don't
forget what demons do they possess the
bodies of others so that they can be
manifested into this world in that
previous video I suggested that the
demon Meggie Kula may not have killed
hacia Silva but rather possessed her
perhaps the demon took control of
osseous Cilla's body and it is still
using osseous body to this day I see a
Silva was the one who trained Manolo
onna but marijuana as strong as she is
never succeeded in defeating assi a once
combined the power of someone like AA CA
with the power of a demon and now we're
approaching a power level that can be
set to surpass the power level of all
magic Knights put together so could it
be that this all
queen of the heart kingdom is actually
Noelle's mother ah CA Silva but her body
is being controlled by the demon Meggie
Kula this would sure make an interesting
twist and it would also explain why this
queen is so powerful but this Queen
could also turn out to be someone else
entirely and she may even turn out not
to be a villain so I don't want to act
like I know for sure what is going to
happen next I just want to stick to my
story that I do not think that OCA Silva
is dead and that rather than dying I
think she was actually possessed by the
demon Meggie Kula but let me know what
you guys think do you think that hacia
Silva is really dead
or is there more to her story also what
do you think about the queen of the
heart kingdom is she a villain is she
actually just a very cautious ruler is
her true identity ah CA Silva let me
know down in the comments I always enjoy
when we get a good black clover
discussion going if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more videos
like it please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications feel free to follow
me on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest black clover
news and updates I want to give a big
thank you to all of our animal / patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell dress on Hell crews stealers
poet Pablo
atropos wraiths fit edala beat karate en
Anatole Cosette's key and Lord a bird
and of course some massive thank you to
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand above all other clans
including Ingrid ah a Lola madam madam
AK makoto-kun and yuh boy Seth if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron only discord and to show our
gratitude your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]